These villains that we now have in our
universe happen to be characters that
are in the sinister six there may be something
that happens with that no matter where he goes
the world is going to be different for him here's
the real blockbuster brace yourselves you might
want to sit out spider-man's name is peter parker
what the f no more hiding. Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie this is going to be my new spider-man
3 sinister six video there's a whole bunch of
new details obviously amy pascal teasing that
they're building up to big mcu sinister six so
we'll break it all down if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
they're filming spider-man 3 right now as we speak
some of you who live near where they're filming
they have spotted some of the cast already we'll
do a new amazon giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and let me know who you
want to be on their sinister six roster and i will
explain who they have so far they actually have
five of the major members they're still a mystery
sixth person that they need to introduce though
but starting with the big stuff first number five
recently tom holland just finished filming on
his uncharted movie and they've started filming
on spider-man 3. like i said some of you may
have spotted the actors filming on set already
ned leeds already looks like he lost a ton of
weight no i don't think that that means that
they're going to turn him into hobgoblin i've
gotten so many hobgoblin questions in the last
couple of weeks he's a really young dude i think
he just got to a point in his life when he decided
that he wanted to get healthy and he had a reality
check moment so i think he just lost that weight
for himself i don't think it has anything to do
with what's going on with him in the movie but
they might have some references to it during the
movie like oh wow ned you just came back after
spider-man far from home and you lost a ton of
weight amy pascal did say that the title of the
movie would have home in it just like spider-man
homecoming and spider-man far from home so post
all your home memes for spider-man titles but
the working title while they're on set filming is
another seinfeld reference they're just referring
to the movie as serenity now which is apt given
spider-man's probable mental stake currently after
he was doxed by mysterio to the whole world and
then framed for his murder amy pascal has been
talking about them doing a new mcu sinister six
team for a couple years now so with the recent
jamie foxx electro amazing spider-man announcement
in the doctor strange 2 crossover multiverse
announcement in the reveal that michael keaton's
vulture is also probably coming back for another
cameo in spider-man 3. the new sinister 6 team
is just starting to take shape and make a little
more sense obviously it's going to be a little
bit different than the original sinister six
comic book team marvel tries to be as comic book
accurate as possible when doing classic spider-man
characters and that's kind of been their mo with
the tom holland spider-man movies they started
with some of the original comic book villains like
the vulture debuted in the amazing spider-man
number two a version of mysterio also kind of
debuted during that same issue right at the
beginning he was camouflaged as an alien but this
is supposed to be mysterio here so it makes sense
that the new mcu sinister 16 would be very close
to a version of the original comic book sinister
16 but we are missing characters like doctor
octopus and craven the hunter both of whom were on
that original team dr octopus himself was sort of
the leader of that version number four yes there's
been a lot of craven the hunter rumors the past
year and big actors saying they'd love to play the
character earlier this year there was even that
supposed casting leak that sony and marvel were
looking for a joel kinnaman type to play a mystery
villain and everyone just assumed that would be
craven there was a bunch of fan art that actually
looks pretty fantastic recently jimmy kimmel even
started using his official accounts in his tv show
to start making jokes that he was going to be
craven in the movie this is the same clip of
him talking to michael keaton where he was talking
about coming back as vulture and spider-man 3 and
coming back as batman in the flash movie you're
like a spider-man guy right yeah i'm going to be
in the spider-man you're going to be in the next
spider-man right i'm going to be cr i'm playing
craven the hunter in the next spider-man movie
this is where everybody's supposed to applaud
all right yeah that wouldn't surprise me yeah
you know we're having discussions as they say
we're talking about we'll see if it happens so
after you watch that it should go without saying
that jimmy kimmel is joking about being craven
in spider-man 3. i was blown away by the number
of people who were genuinely concerned that that
was a real thing all the stuff about the vulture
coming back and michael keaton batman in future
dc movies that was not a joke that's why michael
keaton's saying that he's excited and there's a
lot of interesting stuff happening that he hopes
works out behind the scenes that's him basically
saying that he's haggling with the studios for all
of his batman stuff the big thing about him coming
back in spider-man marvel movies and dc movies at
the same time is really just a scheduling thing
spider-man 3 is going to be filming for the rest
of 2020 and then through the early part of next
year the flash movie won't start filming till
a little bit after that so as long as they pay
him enough money everything will be fine number
three addressing the tobey maguire spider-man
3 concerns that everyone's been posting about
a lot of you have seen all the announcements about
these sinister six crossover characters doctor
strange being a huge crossover character more
venom crossover teasers for future spider-man vs
venom and it's starting to give people some ptsd
for what happened to toby mcguire's spider-man 3
way too many villains way too fast too many
characters to handle and the movie turned into
kind of a mess you may remember aviarod took most
of the blame for that in more recent years because
he's a producer on the venom movies he apologized
for trying to do too much too soon so don't blame
sam raimi for all that he's directing doctor
strange 2 also filming later this year so he
has a solid chance to redeem himself as well and
from the way jamie foxx was talking about coming
back as electro it sounds like he'd be one of
the more major villains in spider-man 3 so any
of the other big sinister six stuff that they
might be doing during spider-man 3 sounds like
it'll be relatively minor by comparison right now
the roster of core bigger sinister six characters
that they have on hand are the vulture scorpion
shocker electro now with jamie foxx's edition
a version of mysterio and then they have an
open slot for the sixth member so it could be
any number of the original classic sinister six
villains number two addressing the spider-verse
multiverse of it all with doctor strange and
electro the whole theme of marvel phase 4 movies
is multiverse doctor strange is a huge avengers
crossover character that's supposed to be a new
mentor to spider-man and spider-man 3 just per
the official description when the announcement was
made like benedict cumberbatch's doctor strange
is sort of filling in the iron man role since his
death in avengers end game they didn't really have
a lot of scenes together during avengers end game
because the battle scene was so big but i love
their scenes together during avengers infinity war
and i feel like doctor strange's creative
use of portals with spider-man's abilities
was great during that thanos fight also spider-man
is based in new york city doctor strange lives
in the sanctum which is in greenwich village
so doctor strange is sort of like the s-tier
avengers character on call in new york city to
make another doctor reference when other heroes
run into world shattering problems that they can't
handle on their own like big multiverse problems
thank you very much scarlet witch we'll get more
of that in Wandavision with her messing with the
multiverse and setting up all these marvel phase
4 twists but doctor strange 2 is the next marvel
movie coming out after spider-man 3. so if doctor
strange is crossing over into spider-man's movie
it's a fair prediction to make that spider-man
will also cameo a little in doctor strange too
is just like thor showing up in the doctor
strange post-credit scene then right after
in thor ragnarok they had a much bigger doctor
strange crossover scene with him helping them out
in talking about electro showing up in the movie
as a villain jamie foxx said he wouldn't be blue
this time obviously quickly deleted his post
after because marvel came after him a lot of
fans assumed after they saw that that it meant
his electro would be a different version than
the version from the amazing spider-man andrew
garfield movies but within that same post everyone
saw that he was also posting toby maguire andrew
garfield's spider-verse art if the multiverse is
such a huge story device during the marvel phase 4
movies doctor strange is going to be there and amy
pascal has already said the studio has thought
about doing live-action spider-verse it's still
totally possible that electro does come from
andrew garfield's spider-man universe but marvel
just re-tunes the way that the character looks a
little makes him look a little more like classic
electro from the comics in a lot of times the
actors don't always know what's going to be in
the final version of the movie like they'll get
pitched an idea but by the time the movie comes
out so many things have changed that it's a
completely different movie and yes of course
number one there's all those rumors recently about
them actually doing full blown spider bursts with
cameos from tope maguire and andrew garfield
coming back as their versions of spider-man
there's the weird tobey maguire spider-man
costume that shows up during the morbius trailer
but until we see some legit actual evidence that
that stuff's happening and those actors are coming
back i think it's better to treat it like it won't
happen that way like spider-verse easter eggs or
no spider-verse easter eggs in the movie those
characters probably won't come back now that tom
holland is actually filming spider-man 3 we'll
just play the waiting game and hope that he does
some sort of spoilery thing before the end of
the year dropping some cool details there was a
sony marketing executive that was quoted recently
saying we get a spider-man 3 teaser in december
before the end of the year but we'll see if that
winds up happening everyone post all your theories
in the comments below leave your video requests
the mandalorian season 2 episode 1 is going to be
dropping on friday that's when my video will post
for that i'll be doing weekly episode videos so
make sure you have alerts enabled for my channel
so you get all those everyone click here for that
brand new marvel shang chi first look teaser
and click here for the brand new mandalorian
season 2 trailer video thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe this is the way!